but there's really two people that  control the economy one is the chairman  of the fed and the other is the U.S  Secretary of Treasury because that's  where all the tax planning comes so the  president very much controls tax and  treasury goes to Treasury and he says  listen this we're going to do on taxes  we're going to do we're going to cut  taxes we're going to raise taxes we're  going to do tariffs and so the Secretary  of Treasury on the left and then Jerome  Powell on the right and the president in  the middle those are the three that will  impact the economy but you're right the  FED very much has a mind of its own  whereas on the other side the president  has control of tax through the secretary